Imagine we have the data
displayed in the scatter plot.
It appears that we have a linear
relationship between the number of
employees and the number of tickets.
The relationship appears to
be linear since it seems like
we can draw a straight
line through the data.
If we know the equation of the line,
we can predict values for
tickets, given a certain
number of employees.
The simple equation for
a line is y = mx + b,
where m is the slope of the line and
b is the y-intercept point.
In our example,
y is the average number of tickets and
can be referred to as
the target variable.
So this is the variable
we're trying to predict.
x, or the number of employees,
is the predictor variable, since we're
trying to predict the number of tickets
based upon the number of employees.
To determine the equation of the line,
we need to calculate the slope and
the y-intercept.
With the equation, we can draw
a straight line through our data.
In this example,
we'll use Google Sheets, but
the same functionality
exists in Microsoft Excel.